[Music]
what's going on youtube this is travis
from chasing anthems coming at you guys
with another reaction video
um i have to say we have not had such a
great response in such a short period of
time then the stevie ray vaughan video
that we recently posted last week link
up here in the description or the little
tag thing whatever you want to call it a
card anyways uh with that being said you
know during the video i was impressed
but i felt like it was a little
lackluster uh compared to the fanfare
and the folks who are dedicated um to
stevie ray vaughan's music so i knew
there was more there so a lot of people
have commented below or commented in the
previous video i'm used to saying
comment below
on various videos to check out and this
was one of them i think i got some of
the most comments back about saying go
check out voodoo child live from austin
so here we are today we are going to
check it out because you guys requested
it this channel is all for you guys to
check out stuff that i am not familiar
with and that helps me grow as well as
support the artists who um who perform
this amazing music with that being said
thank you so much for tuning in today if
you're new to the channel please
consider subscribing liking commenting
sharing doing all that good stuff and
when you get done with this go check out
some of our original music hit the
channel icon and you can go follow us
and check out our original music we got
a new single that's going to be coming
out it's called santa cruz you can find
it on spotify apple music all that kind
of good stuff and we have a whole bunch
of other stuff already out there so go
check it out we greatly appreciate it
with that being said today
let's get in to this video here we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
now
uh before he gets into the vocals here i
was not 100 sure when i first saw this
title if um
because i believe this is jimi hendrix
right voodoo child is a very
recognizable jimi hendrix song unless
jimmy
wasn't the original writer and maybe
somebody else was i'm not sure but this
sounds a whole stinking lot like jimi
hendrix
uh version of voodoo child so
i'm curious is this a note for note and
this is a lot of people recommend it
just because of
um
you know how well he's able to pull this
track off or are we going to get off the
rails a little bit and so that's i'm
curious i'm going to be looking for that
um i love his technique his technique is
amazing i think i mentioned it in the
buckethead video that i recently just
dropped that uh he has a momentary
switch and uh he's pulling it off with i
believe a foot pedal um which is it
rings really cool actually it's more
like a tremolo kind of effect he's got
going on but anyways i i'm curious is
this a note for note copy
or are we gonna go into a whole uh next
level find another gear on this this
ride let's find out
think of all the pieces
my
[Music]
if you'd like to support the channel if
you like to support chasing anthems you
can go to our bonfire site the links up
here you guys can click on that you can
get some of our chasing anthems
exclusive gear through bonfire check
this out we got t-shirts we got long
sleeve we got tank tops we got sweaters
we got hats all you got to do is go
ahead and click on it pick your size
change your color and it will show up at
your doorstep alright also we have some
exclusive mugs i don't know if you guys
listen to apple podcast um or any of the
other podcast platforms but you can get
our exclusive coffee mug with our
chasing anthems and friends logo
plastered on there start your morning
off right with a cup of joe uh if you're
more of a traditionalist and you just
want a regular logo you can have that as
well with that being said thank you guys
so much like i said the links up here
above we greatly appreciate every little
bit of support but with that being said
please go check out original music
because that's what we're all about
do
[Music]
all right i hate stopping it because
i would love to play you know listen all
the way through and i and i will
definitely after this i would have to
say so to me and i don't have the track
side by side but i'm hearing a lot of
variations in stevie's version of this i
do have to say as much as i love jimmy
uh jimmy was a very sloppy guitarist uh
his solos were very
um
dirty and there's something to say to be
said about that i think that that's
awesome and
it's gritty and it's rough and it's raw
and all that kind of good stuff stevie
on the other hand is clean a very
precise
uh technique that he's employing there
and um the one of the things i love
about this song is that that solo
matches the vocal harmony that's one
thing i try to do as a when i'm writing
guitar parts is to try to complement
those vocals
it helps the vocalist stay and keep but
b
it also has that unison in sync and it
sounds really sick so i i'm going to say
this this is definitely not a carbon
copy
it's a take off of that but we're not
even halfway through so let's see what
happens
[Music]
i didn't make you wake up
give it back to
you every day
[Music]
i didn't make you take about your sweet
song
give it back to you
each and every day
god knows
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know something else i gotta mention
is like clearly
stevie's got chops and a sound like no
other i mean
you can tell you just get kind of
mesmerized but the band is really tight
too
um i'm gonna have to look up the uh who
is his bass player because he has really
good
intuition you know you can see that he's
trying to make eye contact or at least
look over his way so that uh the bass
can match the guitar riffs that he's
doing in a tasteful way not a way that's
overpowering or he's going to distract
what uh stevie's going on but so much of
music is feeling
and
um just kind of spending time with each
other knowing what direction you're
going are you pushing are you pulling
and stuff like that and a really tight
band like this you'll notice that
they're just feeling on where are we
going with this right like this song
could have easily been a
a three and a half minute song but um
it's pushing up into the eight minutes
here once we're done i'm not sure if
it's gonna go to another song here but
um
really tight band and that's something
that takes a lot of time a lot of
practice and it takes a lot of skills
from every other everybody else
supporting um you know the front man
who's
you know just feeling the moment right
he's making modifications on the fly and
um and he he's feeling the solo which is
pretty cool um when the artist feels it
the audience feels it as well you know
and that's something that is unique to
live performances which is something we
need to get back after this whole covet
mess so let's go man let's get back to
the shows
so
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go there you have it that's
stevie ray vaughan voodoo child that
right there sums up why i'm modding my
guitar to add a whammy bar there's a
aftermarket uh floyd rose that i'm i'm
working on putting on my um my last paw
which will be an upcoming video for you
guys to check out but
uh that was sick man a little those
little dive bombs at the end and
the pitch harmonics like that there was
a lot obviously it sounded a lot like
jimmy
um
but there was also a lot of originality
in it right he made it his own and those
are the best kind of covers is when you
make it your own
um i still would like to hear an
original original from stevie bravon and
i know there's more in the previous
video comments i'm gonna have to go back
and check out to see which one of those
videos um is recommended that has
original original content but i have to
say this was phenomenal uh this solo is
definitely
um or this take on voodoo charles the
best i've ever heard aside from jimmy
it's hard to tired to be top the guy who
uh i think i believe wrote it but i
could be wrong but anyways with that
being said thank you guys so much for
tuning in i hope you guys like this
reaction video if you're new to the
channel please subscribe hit the like
button comment do all that kind of good
stuff go check out some chasing anthem's
original music by hitting the channel
icon or visiting one of our social media
sites
but other than that i'm gonna catch you
guys the next one peace
[Music]
you